even though you're just going into year
four those younger guys
they're going to be sending like i'm
about to play john moran yeah they're
gonna get cooked too
[Music]
what up
we are back at it
you and me once again but
you know this is like our this is our
annual
interview tradition we always do one
yeah anniversary
how you feeling vegas is something vegas
is hot it is so hot what is it we're
like we're at 100 today right for sure
and 20 30.
um didn't say his name but john moran
everybody uh give it up for draw you
know we do these all the time but you're
certainly much richer this time
big money congrats on that
likely uh going to be up to what 231
million your extension
it's a lot of money
a lot of zeros yeah when you hear that
number what do you think
what do i think obviously starting i
earned it
number one but uh
definitely a blessing you know for you
know me and my family to you know
be able to you know achieve that so yeah
now it's gotta you know keep it going do
you think it's really hit you though
that that's what you're going to be
making
yeah i feel like once it did
uh i was in utah i actually was sitting
on the balcony i recorded a little video
and sent it to my mom dad and little
sister like
you know we made it
i felt like you know that's when it you
know kind of hit me that you know i just
signed you know
for a lot of money yeah
yeah but
um i think everything be weird you know
for me like achieving goals and stuff is
like it'll be a random time like i can
be in the drive-through line and it
might hit me or something so
i'm pretty sure it'll you know come
around again yeah well because i saw you
talking about that moment on the balcony
where you you know recorded the video
send it to your family and you had that
moment with them but when you were
sitting on that balcony just like by
yourself and reflecting what were you
thinking about yourself in that moment
uh pretty much a relief um honestly um
obviously i feel like you know
every you know top pick you know coming
in until you know your
last year well year four
your goal is to you know get another
contract um
really i feel like that's for everybody
in the league so you know
going into year three you know
um that off season before you know i
put a lot into like yeah
we need another contract i was working
hard you know talking with my family you
know about continuing to stay in the gym
staying locked in
had a great year and
the contract came so
it was definitely you know like a relief
and it's like all right now you can just
you know do what you do best and that's
you know play basketball yeah
does this ever feel
surreal for you or have you always said
like this is what my life was going to
be
i could say both honestly you know
basketball i always wanted you know to
play at the highest level um
it was my goal to play at the highest
level and uh
i can't say you know i always thought
you know that's how my life would be but
you know i'm extremely happy and you
know blessed to you know be able to you
know live this life and play the game
at the highest level so yeah and now
we're getting what 500 tips
to the waitresses which you did all the
time like you have always been a very a
very big tipper but in that moment it
felt like it was a little more special
um for sure um
it was actually just chilling in dallas
and
you know i
did a tip i feel like you know it was
the first time where i've i've had
somebody you know
react that way uh pretty much like she
actually ran around the restaurant
after that um the whole time she's just
like
can i shake your hand can i get a hug
and she like
i'll never want to wash your shirt again
so
hopefully she put it up on her walls her
hair's up yeah and now she will be a
grizzly fan like forever for sure she
got to be yeah
yeah and that's i think a really special
thing that you do with a bunch of people
you create these moments like even with
in your camps when all the kids show up
but you're like dunking with them you're
grittying with them like they're gonna
think about that oh for sure um
experience you know you you know
remember forever yeah so one thing about
you you live life you have a very fun
life
um and you are certainly the topic of a
bunch of things on social media because
you're going ig live and showing
everyone the fun you were having
what did you think about the reaction
that people had to you being on ig life
um
that's a good question
um i honestly just feel like you know
in my job my profession that i feel like
you know people kind of
think you know we're not human as well
like
i'm pretty sure i'm not the only one who
goes and have a drink
so
but because i'm on ig live and you know
fans around the world you know see it uh
i feel like they kind of you know blew
it up like you know some was you know
john having the time of his life you
know he's living which you know i feel
like i should you know
i achieved my my dream i feel like every
day you should celebrate life
especially if you wake up that morning i
feel like you can you know you could
never take
uh life for granted so you know that's
why i always preach to you know my
family and everybody you know
to always you know be themselves and you
know enjoy life but then you have some
that's
you know always going to be negative
yeah
and i feel like you just be like all
right oh well i'm gonna do me so
after you know i did that live that's
you know why i said what i said yeah and
i think you also even tweeted just about
like you were going to be who you are
like how you mentioned
but do you ever feel like okay
if i'm doing this and even though we all
know you're in the gym i know you're in
the gym every day but there's something
to people not seeing you in the gym that
makes them think
that you're not like how do you combat
that
um
you know now
i have my mans now who you know follow
me around you know everywhere i go shout
out tonight now i can have you know that
footage
so if i want to post i can
post almost every day if i wanted to but
i just don't feel the need to
um
but you know sometimes i i feel like you
know i have to let everybody know yeah
then
you know from you know
my side uh my trainers uh
my my friends you know they
always make sure you know i'm in the gym
and they actually be in the gym with me
working out i feel like we all you know
hold each other accountable and then to
the grizzly side you know as well um i
feel like you know we all
share that mindset so you know always
wanting to be better yeah
uh i i'm just not gonna post being in a
gym every day right
because you're like i mean i'm clearly
in the gym right yeah i mean you will
wake up every morning and go to the gym
every single day okay that's fair what
do you think your relationship is with
social media like what does twitter do
for you
uh for me um
a lot of things um you know you get to
see you know what's going on around the
world it's opportunity for you know me
to speak up on you know things i believe
in things i don't like i do like
and you know also um to you know promote
my brand um
which is me on my brand so yeah
i feel like you know it helps a lot
obviously you know social media can be
draining for a lot of people
highs and lows
me personally honestly
you know i could get rid of it but you
know
i'm just you know a god who you know
allow people
you know who are fans of me you know to
see you know what i'm doing i tweet
certain things maybe it's song lyrics or
uh prayer or something or even something
me and you know my group has talked
about
pretty much so
and it can be an outlet to some uh you
know who don't you know want to talk to
people in person so
when you talk about like the highs and
lows of social media
how easy is it for you to block out what
people say about you or how difficult is
it do you get caught up in it sometimes
i definitely see it
um
i give a lot of credit to my mom
for you know
keeping me you know kind of in line with
but then sometimes she gives me to go
ahead like all right and then sometimes
i won't even tell her and i just go
ahead and do it and then she'll be like
nope delete it
yeah
but you know it's definitely hard you
know you see everything
now you know technology social media is
so updated to where like i can get on my
twitter and they got like a
section of my name and then you see just
all the tweets about me uh pretty much
so i definitely you know i can't block
it out but
i feel like you know you just got to
pick and choose uh you have to be smart
on you know what you're you know say
what you react to and you know what you
let get to you um obviously it's
always going to be haters but you know
that's come with you know you know you
being you and being successful so you
know i just
take it for what it is
what have you learned to be the things
that you want to give no energy to
and the things that you decide to give
energy to when it comes to what happens
online
oh people just you know try to be you
know real disrespectful um
obviously it's through the internet uh
if i say anything on that has given
them exactly what they want and that's
more likes and retweets obviously i'm
not going to see him it's just going to
be back and forth and you know
that's just something you know
i'm not interested in going back and
forth with somebody yeah yeah i
definitely like i might say a couple
things but then i'm gonna stop
eventually uh
wow
yeah yeah one thing that i think
everyone um
was talking about was this discourse
that happened with your dad t who is the
greatest human ever um but people were
talking about like him being on the
sidelines and so then he decided next
game to wear the shirt that said proud
supported black dad why do you think it
was important for him um to be able to
speak on that as well
um
man my dad is like you said like
a friendly guy like everybody loves him
down the earth
take cares of everybody you know show
everybody you know love no matter if he
knew you for
you know years or three minutes he treat
everybody the same and that's you know
with love and care and
for me you know growing up you know i
always said he was my first hater so now
to see him on the sideline running up
and down jumping up cheering
it was different for me as well
but
now it's like
all right now he's kind of you know
showing me and now he gave me you know
even more confidence when i'm out there
playing that all right if he cheering
that he's happy then i know i'm doing
something right but
for him to you know receive you know the
uh stuff people were saying about him
about you know having his cup on the
sideline like he's a grown man like he
does what you want at the end of the day
but
um i feel like you know every child you
know need that support from their
parents and i don't see like how you get
bash for being you know a supportive you
know father or even if it was
a mother uh
getting badged for you know
showing love to your child and
supporting them and you know
ryan went him to the wheels fall off so
um he's not the the one to you know
speak up too much on it but that's why
i'm here i will for him no for sure
can you also i mean i don't know if
people fully understand you know
obviously the role that he's played in
your life is your dad but also why you
making it to the nba and being a star is
super special to him because of the past
that he has also had in basketball so if
you could explain that oh it's pretty
it's pretty much like you know i'm
living you know both our dreams out um
you know he had that opportunity and you
know instead he
took it to you know stay with me uh
because i was you know about to be born
um
which is
something you know
most people wouldn't you know i don't
feel like it would be an easy decision
for you know most like you have a career
your goal where you wanted to achieve
but you have you know a child on the way
and you took that instead so i know it
was you know definitely a tough decision
and he made that decision to you know be
in my life which once again i feel like
you know every child needs and
as far as you know
living out the dream um
it's crazy uh you know we both you know
have our moments about
you know me being in the nba and then
now it's
not only me and being in the nba but you
know a top player in the league as well
so
um
it's definitely something you know we're
both you know proud about but if we play
it one-on-one you know i would kill him
you know it's so funny watching him at
the games because like all the ones i've
gone to he's also talking trash to the
opposing team like the player when they
are right there inbounding you hear him
turn german chairman him and draymond
actually were going at it like it was i
was at game one of y'all's playoff
series and they were going out and
draymond was like yo yo
i was like
but that's him but um you know everybody
uh
that he's talked trash to you know they
have you know the relationship of you
know obviously respect with each other
and right after the game they you know
dapp up and
uh you know have a laugh together and
they know it's you know me as well so
um it's all love but he always told me
inside those four lines you know you
can't have no friends so
that's him you know 24 7. he's going to
talk
once the game started until it end but
before and after the game you know he
showed love to you know all those
players as well
now speaking of draymond there's been
some twitter fun between uh
between you two um starting with you
talking about the the real estate that
you felt you all were taking up
in their heads
tell me what you were thinking about
when you put that tweet out
um i just felt like you know if i
won a championship i wasn't thinking
about you know
no other team or what somebody said
months ago i'm gonna be you know
celebrating a championship i'm gonna be
you know happy with my teammates but
as you see after they won the
championship everything was grizzly
playing whoop that trick
on a parade
showing it in the club
talking about jaron this and that
i mean i feel like you know when you win
you know you can say anything but
i lost and i'mma still be john at the
end of the day yeah
but it's
social media you know they blew it up
like is it beef is it a robbery but no
like
those guys can tell you uh even after
you know we lost in the series that
you know i told them
i feel like you know it's time you know
for y'all to get another ring um you
know through steph clay and draymond as
well and then they said the same like
you know y'all be back you know we'll
see y'all again it'll be a lot of fun
for years to come but we all competitors
at the end of the day we all battling
you know in this league to you know be
the best we can be and to win
championships and
and that's what comes with it so um
yeah
yeah so you're saying after that series
you knew like you said stefan them
you're like it's time for y'all to come
and get that uh for sure um
honestly i feel like you know coming out
as serious whoever you know it was was a
favorite you know
uh to win the championship and you know
with golden state you know
they've been you know a dominant team
for years and you know now having their
you know three core guys back um and
battling with us you know you definitely
can see that
experience definitely comes into play um
i actually was you know a fan of the
celtics as well
so i that series i didn't pick nobody to
win i was just like man i want game
seven whoever wins wins i'm a big fan of
tatum you know i was actually dming him
as well you know congratulating him on
the wins and like you know
uh we're young so you know there's
definitely no
times where you know you know the league
is in good hands with you know the young
core uh pretty much so i was
congratulating him and you know
kind of hoping you know he he definitely
you know won him a championship you know
to start it for this you know younger
generation
now when you talk about the warriors
series and just you all's match-ups to
come i it's obviously no beef anyone who
says that is is incorrect
rivalry is maybe not the right word but
there is certainly like a little more
edge
to that matchup and there always will be
do you agree with that oh for sure oh
it's because it's golden state like
they've been dominant for years
won you know
what four championships um i feel like
you know when
you gotta go to state on the schedule
you know you you want to come out and
play and you know that's when you play
your best so you put a lot more into it
you know playing them
um you know
with the three main core guys uh
but uh like no rivalry or anything but
um i feel like i said it for years since
i've been in the league you know that's
my my favorite matchup for sure yeah
one thing draymond was talking about
after that and as you all were having
your back and forth online was that
he feels as though maybe we put too much
weight into regular season matchups like
if somebody wins in the regular season
jack i agree uh you agree with that okay
why
because
we say we play golden state first game
of the season we win now it's like all
right yeah memphis coming out of the
west memphis better than go to state but
it's one game
we lost to teams this year that didn't
even make the playoffs so
i feel like you know
i agree with you know what he's saying
on everybody put too much into the you
know regular season i feel like in the
playoffs is
really when you get to lock in you know
pretty much and you know
scout a team because you know you got
them for possible seven games instead of
playing them and having another team you
might play the next day where you can't
you know
so uh
i'm definitely with more you know
yeah i thought that was a really good
point and it speaks to just the
postseason being a completely different
animal for sure like and when we're
talking about who's going to win these
games
it almost doesn't even make sense to say
well in the regular season this happened
because it's just it's just a different
gear yeah different basketball and more
physical
half court you know it's not too many
you know fast break transition point so
it's like you actually get to lock in on
the team and you have to
you know be able to uh go out and score
the ball in the playoffs yeah no for
sure so
with that series i think there was a lot
of talk about like
code and it being physical and all these
things
what is code to you
uh
safe place uh pretty much you know
honestly i don't you know ever think you
know anybody go out to you know hurt
anybody um
for sure like i feel like even if you
don't like a person you're just not
going to go and you know try to in a
person's career or anything like that
but
you know it's just being safe you know
it's just certain you know things you
know you pretty much can't do obviously
we had two ex two incidents you know in
that series where you know players went
out um
but
at the end of the day you got apologies
from you know both of those players you
know who
you know did whatever and
um
i feel like you know we all you know
rooting for each other at the end of the
day you know playing in the league
but
like you just you got to be safe
you got to you know obviously protect
yourself but you know
if you have a chance to
you know stop some or
let somebody keep playing in a series
then you know pretty much you know
just don't do it but
it's over now it is what it is man yeah
i said do you think people made too much
of like you and jordan poole
yeah um even me honestly um obviously i
was frustrated you know how i got hurt
um you know i sent the tweet i actually
once again my mom came into play like no
deleted um then i seen people start you
know trying to talk trash like oh you
deleted us
at that time i probably would have got
fined for the stuff i said but i had to
take that into consideration so but
um it's all good with me i don't i ain't
tripping on that yeah so you were
frustrated but i feel like at this point
you all have spoken you're
cool yeah even uh when we were about to
go to state uh when i was walking on the
court he asked me was i good you know
dapping me up even
some of the other players you know asked
me on the side as well
you know that's what i said that's what
it's all about you know we all at the
end of the day care for each other
all you know
want everybody to succeed so
um i don't think you know it's too much
you know dirty players in this league to
you know go and do you know anything but
after that you know frustrated
in pain not knowing you know
what the results was going to be at the
time
my mom you know pretty much was all over
the place so there's a lot of
frustration you know went into that and
then
after you know the first incident where
they you know everybody was trying to
you know bash my teammate not even
knowing that he apologized and stuff
like he didn't mean to do it um
that went in to play too so yeah and
everybody know i'm one to take up for
you know my people so yeah
i mean it's also i just think it's it's
almost like a pressure cooker like
there's so much frustration you're
obviously all trying to win you're bad
about certain things it's like an
emotional rollercoaster and then
everybody's just trying to navigate you
put getting hurt on top of that and it's
a it's a whole thing i think people
underestimated
how
badly you hurt your eye
like could you
even the next game it was bothering you
yeah
for sure um
another i was frustrated then as well um
no i was back with the docs
so everybody can get this story real
quick there's something nobody knows so
i was in the back little tunnel you know
trying to get my vision back but it was
like blurry it was like
when i go to look a certain way it would
get blurry but like when i was straight
for a minute like i'd be good but as
soon as i looked away it was getting
blurry so i was getting frustrated like
man i can't see
i got hit like directly in my eyes so
we was trying to do eye drops i tried to
go back to the bench
and i was like all right i think i'm
gonna be fine i looked up at the lights
and it went back so then now i was like
man all right
i can't see so i
i think i went back to you know i
trained her like two or three times kept
trying to get eye drops and then
me being a competitor uh my pops always
said you got to protect me from myself
the docs told me uh i couldn't go back
in
until
you know i did a little test of where
you know i actually could you know show
i could see or whatever so we went back
in the tunnel and when was walking i was
already looking at everything
before so by the time they came back
i was like yeah man i can see that's the
exit sign it's a person right here like
i'm covering my good eye
just kept pointing and then i'm like all
right and just took off running so then
i ran to the bench and like coach i'm
ready and then checked back in so then
when i checked back in my vision was
still blurry like i was out there
playing like
i don't know how i did it honestly but
so you're saying you cheated the test
with the doctors for sure so that you
could come back onto the core of play
yeah for sure okay so when you're on
what is everything looking like if you
can't see um like my vision you know
pretty much started to come back but
like it was still blurry a little bit
like if i look too fast or a certain way
so it was like i was trying to you know
lock in so like when i first got back
into the game
i think i had like two opportunities
where uh i could score and i like passed
it and then one was on a fast break and
i normally on a fast break everybody
know i get downhill i even stop at the
three-point line and just pass it desire
he ended up hitting i think it was his
second three in a row
and it was like all right i was trying
to get it they called time out i went
back to the bench
and everybody like you good you're good
and i'm telling them yeah but i was
really trying to get my vision back
then i went down uh i got the n1 uh
going left and then i remember like
uh my brother and then was baseline and
i'm like bro like i really got one out
like i really
couldn't see like if i was looking fast
or whatever so
i pretty much just had to lock in on
whatever i was looking at at the moment
um so it's definitely tough you know
being a point guard you know you see
everything but
that's that was one for the book so that
made it even more special uh yeah i'm
gonna say that'll be like your legend
story when you were in the playoffs with
one eye yeah i don't know if it's up
there with jordan flew game but for me
that's it that's number one right there
well no i mean i i knew that it was like
bad and then you would have gone out
there and you just you just tried to
cheated the test man
sometimes that's what you got to do the
past man
sometimes you got to choose to make it
work
i didn't study
so another thing that sticks out to me
too and not to play like the what-if
game but like i said i was at game one
and so i see when you get the ball
you're going downhill you have that
moment that if you make it you guys win
game one
and you miss that layup yeah and i saw
it on your face how upset you were
do you think about that specific shot
for sure
yeah for sure because you know game one
at home we had home court
it's a layup i make time and time again
so that's why i was really frustrated
like man i actually
pretty much beat the heat i think the
year before off the same layup so it's
like
man you do this layup in your workouts
you do it in practice you do it in the
games and
game was on the line and
you know i blew it so i was you know
pretty much frustrated with that one
obviously going up 1-0
um not saying
you know we would have won the second
game but we end up winning the second
game so now you're going into golden
state up 2-0 instead of
1-1 and you know that's pretty much an
advantage you need you know it's you
know a lot of
i feel like you know you're more
comfortable you know going in um but
there's definitely one yeah then getting
it like my p was already know when i'm
if i come out
uh they'd be you know normally waiting
in the parking lot i come out
if they see how i'm walking they already
know they're like you're good man you
make that layup all the time and i'm
like man i know but yeah like
and it was like um okay did you get
fouled
nah okay uh i wouldn't say does it look
like it for a minute yeah but i mean
it's a playoffs though yeah
uh i feel like you know anybody who
drives to the you know uh the realm
pretty much get a bump or something so
if you want to call a foul like that
then i feel like you know that's kind of
soft so yeah
but
that wasn't why i missed uh yeah i think
clay actually tipped the ball as well
but i still got it off to where i could
have made the layup
but he tipped me like right before i let
it go
yeah i mean because if there's there's
few moments in a playoff series that you
can point to and say that could have
changed some for sure like obviously i
was frustrated with that but
um
it was the rebounding category for us
you know in that series that you know
pretty much hurt us so
i can be like damn man that layup right
there
made us lose the game but you know it's
the little stuff that you know you can
pinpoint and be like
all right if we did this we would have
won yeah
now with game two that was your 47
points yeah low 47. yeah would you say
that was the best game of your career
for sure yeah
for sure
playoffs
second round at that you know i was
first round exit year before so
second round that is golden state
um
after you know going back and forth you
know it with steph
uh
i feel like you know that was my best
one yeah um
another thing uh anthony toliver was
telling me about steph um like you know
no matter what like if you have a bad
game you know the greats always you know
uh come back you know and redeem itself
and you know that was my game that was
my chance
and
for like listen to him like when he was
my vet you know he telling me like you
know how to
carry myself you know how to go about
stuff and like he was speaking on stuff
and then it was i'm playing against
steph when that happened it was like
it was crazy yeah on that you know on
that stage that level uh it's definitely
you know i feel like that was my best
game for sure and also just like that
mental fortitude that it takes to you
know miss that layout that you make all
the time but come back and get 47 like
you said against death somebody that i'm
sure i know how much you
value steph as a basketball player you
give a lot of chances yeah exactly like
no 100 percent i think that
obviously even though the series and the
way that you wanted to you had these
moments within it
that i think showed everybody that both
you and the team like you're not going
away nah no no yeah like the grizzlies
are a team that's absolutely here to
stay but so
yeah yeah but so for you okay obviously
the ceiling for any team is championship
that's what you end up wanting
but as you all get better
what's your floor meaning like
what is something that has to happen
every year or you'll feel like it was
not a successful year like is it the
western conference finals is it the like
what's the floor for you all uh
obviously you know it's we're in the
western conference so
i feel like you know it's a tough
conference i feel like you know year in
year out
you know it's a different team who comes
to the you know playoff pitcher
um
it's pretty much the timberwolves
year before you know didn't make it now
they was in the playoffs you know this
year pretty much had us uh on the ropes
but for us i feel like
number one is definitely playoffs
um but i feel like you know western
conference finals finals is
you know something we have to you know
do each year um
for us you know not to say be satisfied
but you know be happy with the season
even though
this past season we didn't make it but
we had a you know a great year but
now i felt like you know that's just a
start you know that's the beginning and
it's now
it's going to the next level um so
yeah and i mean i do hope sometimes you
sit back and you say like
every year
we've gotten better like every year it's
you've gotten further and then you've
gotten better personally too lost in the
play-in my rookie year
lost first round and second round
but i'm tired of the losing it's time to
yeah
put some ice on my finger
and when you think about that are you
like do you give yourself
the goal of when that needs to happen
the time you want to see that happen
like how do you think of the scope of
winning that championship
um i feel like you know that's it's
tough um obviously you like i want to
win now you know i want to win now but i
feel like you can't put you know that
much pressure on yourself but
uh
one when it's time you know it's it's
time um so
once playoffs hit for us it's like all
right
like this the time right here like it's
not
you know like early in the season you
know everybody goal is you know to win a
ring but
that's a long season
highs and lows um
something i hate injuries like you know
you just never know um but
um
when that time come you know you have to
be ready for it and then you
you got to be like you know it's here so
we got to do everything to you know go
ahead and achieve that goal for us
i don't know if scared is the right word
but for lack of a better word
are you scared of getting injured after
going through
some already yeah for sure
um i even you know wrote my my goals
down you know this season and you know
one of them was to play every game uh
this upcoming season so
uh
my trainers you know definitely can tell
you my parents that
it'd be any little thing like
and i get to panicking and stuff it's
like man like
i'm trying to be out there on the floor
i'm a competitor you know
i'll you know lay my body on the line
you know for my team to be out there you
know to compete and battle with them so
i honestly felt like that
uh golden state series where i couldn't
play was
kind of you know one of the toughest
times of my life
um
from the mental aspect of you know not
being able to be out there you know on
that stage
versus that team in the playoffs who we
know you know a great team win
championships and you know just to see
you know pretty much how close
we were you know to achieving our goal
um
it was tough
so i know obviously it was tough because
you were injured but what made it one of
the toughest times of your life like how
did that toughness manifest in your day
to
um
so just starting like with you know
having to go you know get the mri
you know waiting on the results
i actually left the gym and my people
were still
you know at the gym or whatever they was
texting me and stuff and like i didn't
i didn't know like what to do what to
say at the time like it was just like a
lot going on mine racing is like
is this something that's going to affect
me you know
for you know a year or two or for a
while or is it you know something you
know i could get over you know pretty
much
uh real quick and then
once they told me like yeah man uh
you know the series is you know
you know kind of over like you wouldn't
play you know this series or whatever
and it's like
damn pretty much like yeah so then it's
like
my people's actually with me like i'm
just sitting there and it's like
you know how you can tell when you know
when somebody down and you know you're
just trying to make sure they're good
and stuff but it was like
my mind just was all over the place but
you know having them around you know you
know helped me and then
going back to memphis and coming back to
golden state and i'm still on the
sideline in a tech suit
it was definitely tough so
i had to just keep telling myself you
know everything you know happens for a
reason
i just took it out with an opportunity
to you know lock in on
you know everything and you know put my
off-season plan on to how
to be available
for every game to you know be able to go
out there and play yeah
you know i think that like
nba fans in general they almost
underestimate just like what injuries do
to a player mentally
they talk about it so flippantly like oh
well you can't stay out there or it's
like we'll go out there to the playoffs
but it's not it's not that easy
what would you just want people to
understand about what it does
for you mentally being injured and also
not being able to help your team
um
tough
it's a lot um
you know you want to be out there
knowing you can't that's i feel like the
even tougher part
i feel like nobody in this league uh
would get injured and you know
be able to play and not play pretty much
unless it's like something we like all
right
if i go play i maybe can hurt it worse
or anything so
mentally
it can have you down on yourself
actually it can make you know question
everything like why i had to be me why
at this time
and i feel like for us you know
basketball is our job
our goal was to play at the highest
level we had that opportunity to play at
the highest level
then you injured and now it's like you
can't go out there and play and for us
you know you got your teammates who you
ride for who you
practice and you know go through
everything with day in and day out so
you know you want to be out there and
then for it to be the playoffs where you
know we got the opportunity to win the
ring
it is tough yeah you i feel like you
just gotta you know in every negative
you gotta you know find a positive in it
um
that's what i was trying to do
uh it kind of took me a minute but
you made it yeah i made it
you talked about like almost working on
being available like in the offseason
how do you work on durability i'm not
making sure that you're there for your
team on the court
i give a lot of credit to
uh the trainers you know in the league
and also you know the trainers you know
people have you know on the side as well
but i feel like i'm grateful to have you
know
my trainers with my team and my trainer
my personal trainer to be able to collab
and
be on the same page so i feel like you
know that helps me even more and you
know
they try to teach me you know about my
body all these big words you know
and
uh
it's just you know learning you know
what i got to do what's my problem you
know what's weak
um and then it's you know setting out
this plan to you know not only you know
make your pretty much your whole body
strong but you know certain parts to
prevent injury so mine is
how to prevent you know knee injuries
how i play
um i had
two three
uh knee injuries you know since i've
been in the league so it's now just them
studying that and
finding out what's weak i do all these
tests and stuff now yeah that i hate but
it is for the better so but that also
has to be like a weird back and forth in
your head knowing like
it's your style of play like the thing
that makes you jaw is also the thing
that's like
where you kind of like are gasping every
time you go up or every time that you
drive for sure so like how are you
balancing the thing that makes you good
but also understanding the thing that
could also
hurt you um
it's tough yeah
i feel like
not only tough on me but for my trainers
because it's like
it's how i play and i feel like you know
everybody knows you know
that
how you land a certain way how you
always hitting the floor
you know all this extra stuff that you
know an injury could possibly happen but
it's my playing style is how i've been
playing you know
since i
got athletic i can't say before because
i wasn't dunking this stuff i was short
and all but
um
it's definitely tough but then you have
to
manage it uh pretty much you have to you
know look at
other ways to
not go do that but still you know be a
good player
so for me it's you know shooting the
ball like being more consistent to where
i don't have to go
to the lane every time and receive
contact or you know all this so
i mean that place goes crazy
you're like oh he's
he's versatile
are you talking about your athleticism
tell me the three most athletic guards
in the league right now and you
obviously can say yourself so yeah i'm
definitely i'm number one though
you're number one who's two
athletic cars
i'm gonna honestly go with ant-man
he i feel like he really athletic uh
get off the floor pretty fast
um
zach levy
okay
that's one you can add two more if you
want are you good what you are yeah i'm
number one but i'ma just you know pick
three so
so you're number one and then anzac or
jumble you know who people forget about
i think because we haven't seen him on
the court a bit
john wall for sure
is like
so athletic
but it's so it goes to like when you're
not seeing someone you just forget yeah
but i mean there was there's that run
he's like he might have been the best
yeah like watching him
mm-hmm
for sure i feel like it's a lot of
athletic guards but people game
different you won't know yeah you won't
know if they don't play downhill or
whatever like you know i do so yeah but
he's definitely
one of the most athletic rust still
yeah
you know what i always think about so
like obviously the first time i
interviewed you you weren't even in the
nba yet
and we had this whole part about how
russell westbrook was your favorite
player and that it was going to be
really exciting to be able to play
against him
how has that you know shifted from being
the guy that you like really look up to
to being your opponent um
that respect and
the respect level's still there me being
a fan you know it's still there
but you know once i play
i feel like you know now it's kind of
you know i'm kind of getting used to it
pretty much going into year four now so
i've you know i played them for some
years but
i can say like my rookie year that you
know that first match up it was like
i i want to say it maybe it was
during the bubble
it was during the bubble uh where we
played um
i actually text my people like
dang i'm about to play russ before like
it was like a surreal moment like wow
like i was just watching his film his
highlights
um and now it's like you know i'm
actually going up against him um but as
of now it's like going into year four
it's my job to play against you know the
best players you know players i've
watched you know growing up
um
so i'm kind of i'm kind of used to it
now so now it's
the people who look up to me coming in
the league yeah
i was going to say that's what's wild
like even though you're just going into
year four those younger guys
they're gonna be sending like i'm about
to play john moran yeah they're gonna
get cooked too
it's my job nobody can take that one
which incoming rookie are you most
looking forward to just cooking
kennedy chandler
okay
it's okay but i i see him in a couple
weeks once he you know done with the
summer
[Laughter]
uh
league
between him and jaden you know
i feel like you know i'm the most
closest wick you know and you know that
that rookie drive class um
super excited for both but
obviously kenny kennedy on my team now
but jaden is probably the you know one
i'm you know most excited to play yeah
because
he was just you know
sitting
on the sidelines sitting on the bench
with us
early on in my career and now he's about
to share the floor of me so yeah
definitely a big time moment for both of
us no i love that so when you so
obviously you were a rookie you were
going to play west westbrook you sent
the text to your family
but what has been your like
you are welcome to the nba moment
because you will probably hand that to
some rookies
what was yours where you said okay this
is uh this is different oh it was that
kyrie match up i feel like with my
welcome
to the league moment
um
but then it was a 52 point game
i felt like that was the other half so i
split it yeah
okay
that's so funny okay which player this
postseason annoyed you the most like
they was talking it was just it was too
much
annoyed me the most that's post-season
whether it was their depends on you
whether it was just them talking trash
who was it
pat bill for sure yeah but i like that
match-up like we got respect for each
other you know we
talk you know after the game or whatever
but
man i feel like you know so much people
hate on him but don't respect him you
know for what he he you know he does for
teams um
i feel like he just bring this edge you
know to the table and
it's like everybody
get on the same page with them but
that's probably i wouldn't say annoyed
but i feel like you know the
most fun was probably him because
everybody know i'm a player to like you
know talk back or whatever yeah
so
now you know that was definitely he
definitely was not surprised if it's
happening a few more for you before we
let you go i want to
just read the stacks i think it's crazy
you were the sixth player in nba history
to average at least 25 points five
rebounds and five assists in your age 22
season obviously oscar robertson jason
mcgrady lebron luca those are the others
but when you hear that
and you hear the company
what do you think that says about where
you can be in this league when it's all
said and done
and
one of the you know
greatest to
ever play the game so i could be in that
you know conversation
you know with those guys you know if i
you know continue to improve and you
know keep up what i'm doing to
you know be
you know in that you know conversation
with this
name you know the greats to you know
play this game so it's definitely
motivation
but that's elite company right there
so it's something you know you can't
take for granted but something you
definitely you know got to be happy
about
but i feel like if if it doesn't
motivate you to you know do even more
uh there's something wrong and
i'm motivated so you know i got to keep
going
this past all-star i was there when you
know they did the the top 75 let's say
everybody there
and you were one of the people that
spoke before they introduced the
incoming class of the top 75.
are you sitting there thinking oh when
it's when it's that tough 100 yeah for
sure i'm there for sure once
once it came through and it was like you
have this opportunity i you know
i took the opportunity i don't even like
to read honestly he said
especially in front of a lot of people
like
i just feel like my accent and stuff
you know all people don't understand you
were great
you know once i got opportunity i'm like
yeah i'm gonna take it you know
had the chance to
you know do that and
on that special occasion on a
night for me who was you know well which
was one of you know
uh the best nights you know in my career
you know first all-star
then you know watching the you know top
75 being called out
my mind was like you know next time top
100 i'll be what you know
stefan lebron knows she did like at the
halftime they went back i'd be the one
you know going back and coming back so
i don't know if i'm gonna play with that
many years but
i guess i'll be tired
what did michael jordan say to you did
you meet him uh i actually didn't see
him oh no
like he was walking but
he was
having a conversation um
and i was actually going back to
the locker room where i was actually
coming out of the locker room when i
seen him and it was
you got to go warm up the game about to
start back so
i didn't want to interrupt this
conversation and i had to you know do my
job so it was yeah it was kind of tough
okay so but if you could have talked to
michael jordan in that moment what would
you have said
thank you
i feel like this
i feel like he you know
the reason a lot of people you know want
to play the game of basketball
um
to even you know
be there with them is you know something
i didn't see myself doing you know as a
kid but having that opportunity
uh to be there and you know talk to him
introduce myself
you know just have that conversation
with him
i don't know what i would have said but
yeah
yeah i wish i played in his generation
though yeah you wish you would have
played in his generation yeah why i
heard he was like like just how he you
know go about the game you know just
that mindset he had
i would like to know play against him so
yeah
you know yeah this time you're not
saying i would have cooked uh i would
have cooked them too
you would have cooked michael jordan
nobody got more confidence than 12.
now that's what you're supposed to say i
get it as you should i'm never going to
go and say nobody going to beat me in
101 or any day yeah i don't care what it
is what sport it is soccer who the best
player in soccer
from what we can play
who would you say that's player what
ronaldo neymar messi
messi yeah
you coming here
i want to be the goalie
i want to be the goalie and how matter
of fact somebody set it up set up you
and messi
for sure you know how hard that is
though right
for sure okay but you still want to try
i'm confident
okay tell me the thing that this off
season you want to improve the biggest
leap you can make
um
i feel like it's pretty much the same as
you know i improved each year but you
know still being
you know more consistent you know with
shooting the ball but
like i said you know finding ways to
not be on the floor or having to you
know receive uh contact at the rim
so i feel like you know that part of my
game um as it continues to improve you
know it'll help me with that so
that's pretty much you know what i've
been locked in on uh
when you did the press conference the
other day you said you know i believe we
have all the pieces we need to win a
championship
what makes you say that
um
starting with the organization you know
with
how they you know bring guys who are
bought in and hungry uh pretty much same
mindset and then
after seeing you know how we you know
continue to improve you know uh
throughout the years
um i feel like you know we
have a lot of key pieces on this team
um some great leaders
um and then our young core you know that
we you know pretty much just you know
brought in um
being able to come in and contribute as
well
i feel like you know in this league
you can have
the best player in the world but
you got to have you know the guys around
them and i feel like i have the you know
perfect guys
you know around me to you know win a
championship
and
i feel like you know we got that chance
and you know that's what we're going for
i know that you know the the team in
general has earned their respect to the
league but you two specifically have
earned the respect to the league what's
been your favorite thing that like a guy
said to you after a game um that just
made you feel good about where you are
in the mba right now
um
i honestly don't know
um
i feel like you know
after the games and stuff
you know you normally be like all right
good game you know
stay healthy good luck
but obviously you know it was guys uh
i think all-star
after some games you know top guys in
this league you know pretty much talking
about my game whether it was like brawn
you know or whatever um just to you know
hear guys
like that you know say you know your
special talents here
uh you know it goes a long way so yeah
all right and last thing for you i got
to make sure everybody sees that
he has him tatted on his hand
what made you get that and so that's why
because i don't think people realize
like if you i don't know you have a good
lay up a good dunk and then you do this
i don't think they get you're tapping
the hymn the hell they just
okay way too early rookie of the year
pick
who do you think wins it because if you
write you know we're going to play to go
play this clip when they win
jail
jada what makes him special
i just feel like you know his
his hunger um
i feel like
that goes a long way not even you know
talking about you know what he can do
you know for a team you know
offensively or whatever but like even
talking with him like in college or
whatever he probably could have
a great game for most people
but for him it's like all right and i
i've seen the same thing with myself so
you know just seeing that and
how he can you know score the ball you
know
from you know all three levels uh
i feel like
yeah you know he he got a chance
obviously you have
you know the top three picks
um
you pretty much don't know how how
that's gonna go
but um i feel like you know
he he'll win it yeah i normally don't
like player comparisons but the jaden
and john comparison feels very spot-on
and at my library yeah yeah so that one
that one works um we got any
live questions from the stream we're
live by the way i don't know if you knew
that
but y'all gotta ask
there might not be any good ones i just
wanted to make sure
well everyone's talking about you versus
michael jordan right now
blow up
and i couldn't
but if you if if
mike was me when he was talking about
the greats before him he wasn't saying
they would beat him either yeah he would
have said the same thing for sure that's
that mentality you got to have to be a
killer in this league
oh this is a good one if you could get
one they said one attribute from the nba
but like i probably i think it means
like if you could go out winning as like
the most something player
in the nba what would that be like
you're known as the one
person that did this
does that make sense like you mean like
is he known as like the most athletic of
all time or the most exciting the most
like shaq's the most dominant like
what do you want your adjective to be
exciting the most exciting
yeah outside of the best player in the
world
yeah you like putting on a show yeah for
sure like you're very aware
that you're putting on a show when
you're out there it's honestly be crazy
like
i really just
go out and play like it's like if i'm
going for a dunk or something it's like
when i jump whatever you know i just
plan on doing in the air i pretty much
do or if i'm coming and i make a pass
however i get to pass there it's just
pretty much me and how i play so
sometimes i don't even
recognize i did something to after the
fact like the 360 layups they
they not playing at all yeah
you know you uh used to haven't got that
lebron done but you talked about last
season i gotta i got some years though
bro yeah
a lot of people asking
about
katy trade rumors
he'll come to the grizzlies if he came
what would you think
i guess we'll find out
um last thing a lot of people in memphis
are in the chat asking what's your
favorite spot in memphis or some of your
favorite spots to go to eat
anything probably go out eat
favorite spots in memphis
i just got into bowling
you good
no
but i beat anybody in this live chat
i'm not good but i win
y'all can try to let it fly it's
actually mike miller's spot that's one
of my top spots i go to
not a little private room if you need
your little room in there everything you
need
wing
get you some wings man
you know what we need new um
we need new like wreck activities
because we golfed we weren't good yeah
and you're saying you're
not good at bowling yeah but if tiger
want to play golf we can though okay and
would you win for sure
right
all right we're beating tiger went to
golf or beating micah we're doing all
the things mercy messi come on
well this is a pleasure as always we'll
we'll do it again in a year
always
anniversary thanks time for me every
year
[Laughter]
is saying in the live chat i can sing
better than you no okay but hold on
actually
admit i actually can sing better than
you you got it you got it i got a lot of
my i can't right now i mean you know
vegas done some stuff in my vocals
because i'm gonna say i i'm good at
everything but say you can sing better
[Music]
but i i i can't now she can't sing y'all
go to a karaoke bar
no no no no no no maybe one day i'll put
some footage out sure yo i do karaoke
yeah i get into it i got y'all too
though
wait what's your go-to karaoke song
cause you won't you don't do it you just
go oh
until the end of time
by justin timberlake really that's a
banger right here i almost started
saying it just now i wanted you to
that's what i am
good we all good
live y'all gotta wrap up next year maybe
next year
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
you